when the unthinking consciousness
declares observation and experience to
be the source of truth what it says may
well sound as if only tasting smelling
feeling hearing and seeing were involved
it forgets in the zeal with which it
recommends tasting smelling and so forth
to say that it has no less essentially
determined the object of the sensuous
apprehension and this determination is
at least as valid for the object as is
the sensuous apprehension
it will also readily admit that it's
concern is not wholly and solely with
perception and will not let for example
the perception that this penknife lies
alongside the snuffbox pass for an
observation what is perceived should at
least have the significance of a
universal not of a sensuous particular
we've now reached paragraph 244 and so
what that means is that we've started
the section observing reason which is a
portion of reason itself right reason is
this massive section that's split into a
number of sections and subsections and
now we're starting the very first
determinate subsection of observing
reason which is observation of nature
and what we see here is this very short
paragraph is Hagel already setting
things up setting the trajectories
setting the orientation for where we're
going so reason in this section at least
for some early parts of it it is
primarily oriented towards looking at
what is not reason itself not the
rational subject but what we might call
the object for reason now of course it's
finding itself there as we've seen
Hegel's already talked quite a bit about
that but there's an agency that's
involved so he talks about an unthinking
consciousness here in the passages to
come he's also going to talk about it
you know reason in it's sort of
instinctual state and so that's what
we're dealing with your reason in a
rather crude and and raw state but one
in which it starts to show its powers
its capacities right and the the German
term here is you might say thoughtless
not just unthinking but lacking thoughts
not not thinking things through that
doesn't mean that it doesn't have any
ideas it's got plenty of ideas but those
are we might say matters representation
if we want to read that in here and
unthinking consciousness attends to
observation and to experience or farm
and as what he calls sources of truth
and sources here is is capela the you
know you might think of it not just as
criteria but where truth is going to
come from and as we go a little bit
further with this you should you know
ask yourself have we Traverse
this path already and the answer is yes
this is part of the the path that we
traversed with set certainty and you
notice another term here that
corresponds to something we've already
gone through perception of our day one
so why is he doing that well remember in
the Hegelian dialectic as it's being
done here in the phenomenology we go
through the same processes but we deepen
it you know on the second the third hint
Abbot more is being added and also some
some of the non-essential stuff is being
stripped away so he says here in this
quite important passage unthinking
consciousness main well sound is if only
tasting smelling feeling hearing and
seeing the five senses the M finden were
involved so is that really what's going
on he says it forgives in the zeal with
which it recommends these things
sensation to say that it has no less
essentially determined the object of
this sensuous apprehension that's the
infinite and this this determination is
at least as valid for the object as is
the sensuous apprehension so what are we
actually sensing when we are you know
smelling things when we're tasting
things right I just Hannah for example a
nice meal of angel hair and pasta sauce
right do I say I'm just tasting tomato
even if I say I'm tasting tomato I'm
already identifying it as something
dressing oh I'm tasting the particular
flavor profile of sweet but also sour
and you know so on and so forth I
identify it with objects I identify with
things that I can point to Hagen will
talk here in terms of like the
perception of the pen knife next to the
snuff box probably not something we can
relate to but you know you can easily
relate to for example a piece of chalk
that is next to the chalkboard in my
hand which is you know
just getting out of this jacket right we
can talk about these things as objects
that we perceive Hegel wants to steer us
from the very beginning into realizing
that this is not all there is for a
reason then again we're traversing that
that path that we've already seen before
what are we actually engaging some sort
of universal so he will say what is
perceived should at least have the
significance of a universal not of a
sensuous particular why Argan is the
universal matter well if we're thinking
about a reason and we're thinking about
what it is that reason is attempting to
do to know things it can't simply know
them just in terms of the pure sensuous
confronting us experience right and it
can't do it solely in terms of the thing
and its properties it has to grasp them
as a universal and now this is going to
be a problem because universals for
Hegel aren't something you might say
quite so straightforward and and you
know staying in their places as they are
for many other philosophers we see
there's a lot of dialectics involved in
figuring out just what is a universal
and how does it work but that's for the
paragraphs yet to come
this Universal is thus to begin with
only what remains identical with itself
its movement is only the uniform
recurrence of the same action
consciousness which thus far finds and
the object only universality or the
abstract it is mine must take upon
itself the movement proper to the object
and since it is not yet the
understanding of the object must at
least be the remembrance of it which
expresses in a universal way what in
actuality is present only as a single
item this superficial raising out of
singularity and the equally superficial
form of universality into which the
sensuous object is merely taken up
without becoming in its own self a
universal this activity of describing
things is not yet a movement in the
object itself the movement is really
only in the describing of the object the
object is described as lost its interest
when one has been described then another
must be started on and continually
looked for in order that the activity of
describing shall not come to an end if
it is no longer easy to find new whole
things then we must go back to those
already found divided and analyze them
further and bring to light fresh aspects
of thing hood in them this Restless
insatiable instinct can never run out of
material to discover a new genus of
major importance or even a new planet
which although an individual possesses
the nature of universal can be the lot
only of a lucky few but the line of
demarcation of what is distinctive of
say elephant oak gold of what is genus
and what species passes through many
stages into the endless
particularization of the chaos of
animals and plants of rocks or the
metals and Earth's etc that only force
and skill can bring to view in this
realm where the universal is
undetermined where particular ization
approximates again to singleness and
again here and there descents to it
entirely there is opened up an
inexhaustible supply of material for
observation and description but here at
the boundary line of the universal where
an immense field is opened
for that instinct it can have found not
an amendment immeasurable wealth but
instead merely the bounds of nature and
of its own activity it can no longer
know whether what appears to possess
intrinsic being is not really something
contingent what bears in itself the
impress of a confused or immature feeble
structure barely developing out
rudimentary indeterminate Ness cannot
claim even to be described
Hegel will begin in paragraph 245 by
talking about the universal that we just
brought in in the previous paragraph and
by the end of it it's going to be very
clear that the universal that's being
grasped does not quite what we're
looking for it's as we put it here
abstract and superficial no wine it is
is that the case part of the answer to
this lies in what he talks about in the
very first sentence of it being a
universal that is Universal by remaining
self same and we've seen that that sort
of lack of dynamism in a universal is
going to be a problem that shows it's
not really a universal or it's a
universal in sort of a lesser sense but
where does angle going with this in this
whole discussion he's going to pass
through this really interesting
discussion all sorts of things that we
can observe and we might get interested
in you want you to think about you know
for example if any of you have this sort
of experience of being a kid getting a
chemistry set or taking any earth
science class and you go home these
circle observing things and you have a
teacher let's say who's or you know an
instruction book that you can make sense
out of that isn't totally baffling you
and you begin attending to the features
of things and it's as if an entire world
opens up for you now for many people
this this experience can go on and on
and on you can lead them to become
scientists or to get involved with
things in other ways you know you know
we don't necessarily have to think of it
in terms of science we need to think in
terms of say culinary arts people who
enjoy not just quicking things but you
know taking them apart and figuring out
how they work and then recombining them
mechanics we could go on and on and on
with this
what Hegel is talking about here is a
kind of dynamic that we've already seen
happening
and put some stuff down here something
happening in the self consciousness
section when self consciousness engages
with things in the world and transforms
the objects that it encounters remember
who did that it was the slave right we
also saw in terms of thought stoicism
skepticism the unhappy consciousness
trying to carry out this transformation
as well it's not just the servant though
because there's a aspect of consumption
or enjoyment that's going on here but
there's going to be a repetition that is
going to render every possible object
for reason as originally fascinating and
then very quickly stale and and
valueless as we put here superficial
superficial Universal so let's see what
he says he says it's movement the
universal movement is only the uniform
recurrence of the same action there's
there's now you know it's good they have
sameness isn't it think about Socrates
and you know when he's talked to in a
very condescending way by several
different people including Kali's saying
you just keep saying the same stupid
thing over and over again so I actually
says well there's a virtue to that in
that you know that I'm actually saying
something reliable if not you know
necessarily true but hopefully it's also
true because it keeps coming back to the
same point Hegel is going to be pretty
receptive to that coming back to the
same point but it better have
transformed itself on the way that's not
what's happening with this kind of
universal and the key question that I've
gotten around where how does
consciousness grasp its objects they can
grasp it in sort of an you know abstract
way by going from the singular the
eyes'll night singularity here to the
universality allgemeine height which is
remaining so sane then he says
consciousness thus far finds in the
object only universality must take upon
itself the movement
proper to the object and since it does
not get the understanding of the object
must at least be the remembrance now
that's an interesting in India
consciousness
why does consciousness have to remember
the object because it has experienced it
right and it has to keep it within the
thesaurus the storehouse of its memory
and in doing so Hegel thinks that
there's a lack of movement a lack of
dynamism that's occurring here he says
this expresses in a universal way what
actually is present only as a single
item this superficial raising out of
singularity why is it a superficial
raising out of singularity and the
equally superficial form of universality
into which the sensuous object is merely
taken up with out here's the answer
becoming in its own self a universal
what does he call this this is the
activity of describing things the
activity of description there is a
movement that is taking place here
within the object the object of what is
being observed and experienced right
this singularity is transformed into a
kind of universality that is what is
there in the object and now we describe
the object we say what it is what
characteristics it has perhaps we don't
even need to describe it necessarily
just in terms of words perhaps we do so
graphically perhaps these days we do so
in terms of you know if you think about
digital technology we do so in terms of
ultimately ones and zeroes what's going
to happen is that there's a movement
within the object that that Hegel calls
description right and then there's a
movement from object to object to object
to object sort of in a relentless and
Restless way they can't ever truly be
satisfied reason is hungry that word
doesn't come up here right reason he has
a
desire but that's what's going on yet
then this passage and the passages yet
to come so he says the object is
described has lost its interest now why
well once you described it you've gone
away from what there was that was
singular you know unique perhaps you've
been fascinating about the object he
turned it into something else so you see
an ant crawling around down there and
you're paying attention to it and now
you're grass but as ant and that little
particular ant is no longer quite so so
important so interesting now maybe you
can think in terms of larger structure
at column and communication but it's the
longest we're just thinking ant that
doesn't matter which can't you pick
they're all pretty much the same right
so you're the nominee says when one has
been described that another must be
started on this is what you see it with
these objects and continually look for
in order then the activity of describing
shall not come to that
so there's describing an individual
thing and others describing as this
ongoing process that is the activity of
reason and I get put here it's a working
on or consuming objects no longer
working on them or consuming them in the
sense of taking you know grain and
turning it into bread and then turning
that into a nice table to feed to the to
the rich or the powerful or whoever and
then eat the husks that they give you
rather it's working on and consuming the
objects of the world as objects of
knowledge as objects that we can make
sense out we can form concepts of now he
goes no no he says it's no longer easy
after a while to find new whole things
so that we must go back to those already
found and divide and analyze it further
so it doesn't necessarily just have to
be a you know totally moving on from one
object so the next we can go within
anyone get an object and find all sorts
of other objects
within them to analyze and it's the same
same basic process though that's
happening right we can split them up we
can look at their larger structures by
which they relate to each other but
we're still doing the same basic process
of description here so it goes anatomy
says this restless insatiable instinct
can never run out of material to
discover a new genus of major importance
or even a new planet which although an
individual possesses the nature of
universal can only be the lot of a lucky
few all right look the great discoveries
right and even today you know we're
still getting news about you know new to
the new species of octopus has
supposedly been discovered we'll see if
it really is totally new by doing
analyses of it you know we can go on and
out of that new all new species of
dragonflies were discovered in Africa
wonderful news but that's what he's
talking about here so he says the line
of demarcation of what is distinctive of
say elephants are overgrown
what is genus and species passes through
many stages into the endless
particularization of the chaos of the
animals and plants rocks or the metals
earth and the force and skill can bring
to view what is what is he talking about
her again this is this process of going
from individual particulars to
universals engaging in description of
them and then moving on to the the next
thing or moving on to a part of that
thing we're moving on to how that thing
is related to another thing and he says
in this realm where the universal is
undetermined where particularization
approximates against a singleness and
again here and there in a sense to it
entirely there is opened up in an
inexhaustible supply of material for
observation and description so
observation and description oscillates
back and forth between singleness and
universality but it's doing so in terms
of the sensuous right anything goes on
he says here at the boundary line of the
universal word am s field has opened up
for that instinct it can have found not
an immeasurable wealth when
not the wealth that it's seeking not a
playground in which it will never be
bored not a library if you're sort of
like me you know Jorge we'd birthdays
who talks about you know heaven he
imagines as a library right but where
you could sit and read things forever
but rather what what it discovers is the
limitations of reason and nature it
discovers a can poverty there and it
wants to overcome that it wants more in
other words it may not it may want more
than really could be made available to
it that remains yet to be seen so need
to include this by saying what bears in
itself the impress of a confused or an
immature of people structure barely
developing a rudimentary indeterminate
'no scan that claim even to be described
the further that we get down into the
vague the in covet the further we get
away from this this description you also
cannot by the way provide a description
of the limits of description but that's
that's another subject so where are we
going to go from here well that's what
we have to see in the next paragraph
while this searching and describing
seems to be concerned only with things
we see that in fact it does not run away
into sense perception on the contrary
what enables things to be intelligently
apprehended is more important to it than
the rest of the complex of sensuous
properties which of course the thing
itself cannot dispense with but which
consciousness can do without through
this distinction into what is essential
and what is unattentive
the notion rises above the dispersion of
the sensuous and cognition thus makes it
clear that it is just as essentially
concerned with its own self as with
things this duplication of what is
essential gives rise to hesitation on
the part of cognition as to whether what
is essential and necessary for cognition
in so also in respective things on the
one hand the differentiate enable
cognition to distinguish one thing from
another but on the other hand it is not
the uneffective things it has to be
known but that characteristic whereby
the things themselves break loose from
the general continuity of being as such
separate themselves from others and are
explicitly for themselves differentiy I
are supposed not merely to have an
essential connection with cognition but
also to accord with the essential
characteristics of things and our
artificial system is supposed to accord
with nature's own system and to express
only this this follows necessarily from
the notion of reason in the instinctive
reason for in this observational
activity reason operates only
instinctively has all also in its
system's achieved this unity that is its
objects are themselves so constituted
that they contain in themselves and
essentiality or a being for self and are
not merely the accident of a particular
moment or a particular place the
distinguishing marks of animals for
example are taken from their claws and
teeth for in point of fact it is not
only cognition that thereby
distinguishes one animal from another
but each animal itself separates itself
from others thereby by means of these
weapons it maintains itself in its
independence and its in its detachment
from the generality the plant on the
their hand does not attain to a being
for self but merely touches the boundary
line of individuality it is at this
boundary therefore where there there is
a show of division in two sexes that
plants have been studied and
distinguished from one another
what however stands on a still lower
level cannot itself any longer
distinguish itself from another but in
being contrasted with it gets lost being
that is at rest and being that is in a
relation come into conflict with each
other a thing in the latter case is
something different from what it is in
the former state whereas the single
individual maintains itself in its
relation to something else
what however is unable to do this in qua
chemical object becomes something else
than it is empirically confuses
cognition and gives rise to the same
conflicting views as to whether it ought
to keep to one side or to the other
since the thing itself does not remain
identical with itself and in it the two
sides fall apart
there is a lot going on here in this
paragraph number 246 and I have charted
out quite a bit of it on the board but
you're going to have to do some you know
sir reading between the lines because
there's so much happening that I
couldn't fit it all on here cable is
going to start up but I've been making
an important distinction between the
essential and non-essential something
that we've seen him do many times before
and he's actually in this pass that
you're going to talk about two different
essentiality Zoar two different ways in
which things are essential one is going
to be the notion and the other is going
to be what we call the differential yeah
and we'll talk about precisely what he
means by that that's a technical term
that we use in in logic but also in
other matters but mainly derived from
logic so let's serve already starts he
says well the searching and describing
seems to be concerned only with things
we see in fact it does not run away into
sense perception why because sense
perception is actually the on essential
so we just saw in the previous paragraph
this interplay between the the sensible
particular thing and the universal that
was it's still in some respect abstract
or or superficial now Hale is big steers
toward something that would be more
substance than that what he's calling
the notion that the cria right the the
concept it says on the contrary what
enables things to be intelligently
apprehended what is that as the notion
when we grasp something intelligently
we're not just doing so through our
senses our senses are great nothing
wrong with them it's just that they
don't provide us with the
intelligibility of the thing could be
that you don't get the intelligibility
without it you know some involvement of
the sensible particular that
summer issue Hagel probably wouldn't
have problem with with saying that you
know for those who really get hung up on
that but certainly the sensible
particularly is not the whole story and
it's not even the essential part of the
story for Hagel and this is what's going
on for observing reason he says what
enables them to be intelligently
apprehended is more important to them
the complex of sensuous properties which
of course the thing cannot dispense with
because it wouldn't be that thing of it
do you have those properties right but
which consciousness can actually do
without consciousness can think the
thing or even in a certain sense know
the thing in its intelligibility without
worrying about those those sensible
properties which are going to vary you
know according to sensibility if you
think about site and how this book
appears to you I'm going to actually be
changing the way this this book looks by
the way I use the editing software and
you know it to be a book right and you
know what to be this book Hegel's
phenomenology of spirit this is not a
great example because there's some
problems one could raise with it but you
get the general idea of what I'm saying
there so he says there's a distinction
into what is essential and what is an
essential and the notion rises above the
dispersion of the centrist then the
notion has a unifying aspect to it this
is very important it doesn't just unify
in a sense of bringing together sensible
particulars the notion is a unification
of the thing as object with
consciousness as subject where you might
say another way to frame this the thing
is brought within consciousness by way
of the notion and when the notion is
truly worked out the notion encompasses
the knower the subject the acting
subject who is you know forming the
notion so he says cognition makes it
clear that it is just as essential
concerned with its own self as with
things no no big surprise there we've
seen this come up number of times now it
says there's a duplication of what is
essential why is there a duplication
well there's a duplication of this as
the essentiality of the thing and then
there is also the essential as the
differentiate this is a technical term
that we use you could just as well
translate those differences if you like
that's just a Latin you know word for
difference right and what the
differences are are what separates the
thing from other things what allow us to
pick it out as what it is another way
you could think about this is the
differentiator that's the sensible
properties right that's how we register
them well they're also what is
intelligible what is understandable by
the thing and they allow us to say all
right this thing not these things over
here so for example saying chalk right
you know we can say chalk is a type of
writing substance how is it different it
you know leaves its residue of calcium
carbonate I think behind and I on the
thing we rather than graphite rather
than ink that's a difference right now
that is something that tells you
something about truck somebody confused
what's the chalk stuff well it's that
stuff over there that leaves that kind
of residue see that's that's not that's
how it works
separate it off so it is really
something essential and it says the
differentiy I enable cognition to
distinguish one thing from another on
the other hand it's not the unassembled
a SPECT of things it has to be known but
that characteristic whereby the things
themselves break loose from the general
continuity of being as such now that is
a really interesting thing to say and
that's part of what gives you the you
know
the reasoning for Hinkle talking about
animals and claws and all that stuff and
making this you know distinction between
different levels of being alright Hagel
has a very dynamic understanding of
cognition and of nature so it says
difference that differentially I are
supposed to get an essential connection
with cognition and they're supposed to
accord with the essential characteristic
of things and our artificial system is
supposed to accord on system and to
express only this so what's going on
here nature and reason ideally he should
equal each other that's not actually
going to happen that's right
so let's actually put a not equal thing
there but that's that's what reason is
striving for reason is striving to you
know make sense of the natural things
that it is observing to take them into
its own purview to find the
intelligibility that is supposedly out
there in nature and how is it doing that
these differentiy I are a key component
of that
so he goes ahead and he says this is
this follows from the notion of reason
and the instinct of reason for it and
that's observational activity reason is
only operating instinctively here and it
says that the objects so constituted
that they contain themselves an
essentially or a being for itself and
are not merely the accident of a
particular moment or a particular place
the research talking about animals
animals are distinguishable from each
other right the giraffe has a long neck
you know you think about all the stuff
or think about the see anything right
the cow says Moo the goat says baa the
dog says woof woof or ARF or whatever
the rooster says cock-a-doodle-doo these
are differences these are these are
sensuous
right but we could say well the reason
why the dog says bark bark is because it
has its constituted in a certain way
that its vocal cords are arranged in
certain ways Hegel talks in terms of
something a bit more violent in terms of
claws and teeth right why is he talking
about that because heard of the nature
of animal life as he's going to point
out here this beautiful passage is not
only to distinguish itself from other
things in our minds so that we sort of
superimpose that order animals can be
understood as distinguishable from each
other because they do in fact
differentiate themselves through the use
of their abilities right they do so in
terms of their their notion there
there's genre our species they do so
also in terms of individuality now they
don't think of themselves as individuals
in the same sense that human beings do
but they do exhibit a kind of
individuality and Hegel says is lacking
at the level of plants a little bit
later he says here we go the plant does
not attain to a beating for self but
merely touches the boundary line of
individuality why there's a show of
division in the sexes and we study that
what what stands out still lower level
cannot itself any longer distinguish
itself from another but in being
contrasted with it gets lost and this is
where a handle is were I think we would
probably say Hegel is saying things that
we would no longer really accept he's
saying that at the level of you know
non-organic or even organic but but not
at the level of plants beings composites
we don't really know what we're working
with he talks in terms for example of
things being different in the empirical
way that we grasp them and in the
chemical way or you got to remember too
that chemistry was a science that it was
you know a much more rudimentary State
at the time
but people were very impressed by it as
well so he goes oh honey says what is
unable to to do this to maintain itself
in relation to something else
through through its differences right
empiric if it gives it confuses
cognition gives rise to the same
conflicting views as to whether it ought
to keep to one side or to the other
since the thing itself is not being
identical with itself in the two sides
well part of the unity is is just not
there it's not that important of a point
where he's he's going with this we're
going to see quite a bit of this by the
way as we go on in previous sections I
haven't taken issue with Hangul too much
there's gonna be places where we're
going to say well you know I think we
can accept a lot of this but perhaps
what he's saying about this is a little
less plausible and that's that's the
case but this is very important this
this notion that we have two kinds of
essentiality x' here a duplication of
essentiality so we should expect that
somehow the notion and the differences
are going to be connected with each
other we're gonna watch how this plays
out in the paragraphs yet to come